quittons kiev pour le dombass dans l'est
de l'ukraine s'est on le rappelle la
principale cible de moscou désormais
l'émission renforcer leur dispositif
les villes sont sous le feu incessants
des frappes russe nos envoyés spéciaux
se sont rendus dans une ville haute en
symboles celle de vietto ya ce qu elle
abrite un important monastère les
habitants ukrainiens sont divisés entre
pro et anti russe reportage karim
yahiaoui mohamed farhat et baigorri v
prick
à monastère immaculé baignée par les
eaux du d'onex l'image ressemble à une
carte postale nous sommes à fiat au
risque dans la partie nord du dombass le
front est tout proche les russes ne
serait qu'à une dizaine de kilomètres
ce sera vrai il n'y aura pas d'attaqué
qui le menace
il ya un possible
d'ici n'ont que nos soldats sont l'un je
reste un cas à
caser snh et
le monastère de viata iasc dépend du
patriarche de moscou
beaucoup n'imaginais pas que les russes
puissent le frapper pourtant il porte
les stigmates d'un tir de missile
militaire nous explique anonymement que
ce lieu ça est une épine dans le pied de
l'armée ukrainienne comme celle où tu
n'as tu as ce monastère n'est absolument
pas l'amour ni ps trop visionnaire
a choisi son art et ce n'est pas celle
que vous pourrez voir conquérir notre
nom où était susi toi c'est en effet ce
dernier chose été chiche terrestre avec
l'invasion russe beaucoup d'habitants de
l'est du pays
aux fruits vers l'ouest via de lire
certains ont choisi de partir à l'est
trouvé refuge en russie et parmi ceux
qui sont restés il y en a qui ne voient
pas les russes comme avant
certains
avanceront sécurité derrière
cette femme ne cache aucunement ses
opinions
le président a voulu adresser ses
occasions il faut
dire que c'est fini contre la russe est
la casa nestlé voient ça ne feriez pas
en tant que maître livre ait que les
panneaux et certaines
routes il devient pas se mêler de nos
d'ambiance et changer le ton basse d'un
côté des habitants qui accueilleront les
soldats russes sans état d'âme de
l'autre ceux qui espèrent que l'armée
ukrainienne sera capable de tenir ce
pont un des derniers encore debout dans
les environs
dans cette ville divisée souvent les
habitants qu'ils soient pro russe ou pro
ukrainien espère que le monastère ça de
ce bateau qui risquent les protégera